good evening welcome to the science
industry Business Library my name is
Jackie gold I'm a librarian here and
also the coordinator of the public
programs tonight's program is warped
passages unraveling the mysteries of the
universe hidden dimension tonight the
center is Lisa Randall who's professor
of physics at Harvard University she's a
leading theoretical physicist and expert
on particle physics string theory and
cosmology she's going to discuss her
book that examines the path of discovery
from early twentieth century physics to
the razor's edge of today's particle
physics and string theory so please join
me in welcoming professor Lisa Randall
thank you for having me here it's really
a pleasure to be speaking at the New
York Public Library I grew up in Queens
I recently found out that it's actually
a different library system but but it's
still I think that the general
educational component and these cultural
events are really fantastic and I think
it's great there you do this I'm going
to just be speaking tonight about my
book war passages I'll be telling you
about the extra dimensions part I should
say when I first started doing physics I
had no idea that I would end up working
on something as out there as extra
dimensions of space but what I'm going
to try to do in this lectures is
convince you why as a physicist not as a
science fiction writer but as a
physicist we would be interested in this
subject and why extra dimensions could
potentially have real impact on what we
see in our world doesn't mean that there
will be applications immediately of
extra dimensions but it does mean it
might help us understand some physical
phenomena that we can measure and
observe and hopefully can even test for
them within the next five years um the
title warp passages refers to the kind
of geometry that I'm going to be
discussing later on Einstein showed a
while ago most 100 years ago that we can
associate gravity with the geometry of
space-time
and how space-time is curved and what
I'm going to talk about our extra
dimensional theory
is in which space-time is curved in a
very particular way so warped has has
actually a very particular meaning and
the warping of space-time is so dramatic
that it's going to lead to some very
interesting physical phenomena which I
hope to explain um the title was also a
little bit of a wordplay because it was
my first book so I thought war passages
was an appropriate description but also
I think war passages is nice in the
sense that sort of describes both how
people understand and how we arrive at
these ideas it's not necessarily some
direct route where we're saying let's
solve this problem we get and get there
immediately and in the book I describe a
little bit really how how we ended up
working on these um quite unconventional
ideas what I'm going to try to tell you
about today is really a new worldview um
there really are many new results in
theoretical physics in the last decade
and some of the most exciting of them
involve extra dimensions of space both
in terms of theory we've really
discovered interesting consequences of
Einstein's theory of gravity that just
hadn't been known before it's really the
theory we know but applying it in this
extra dimensional context with some new
ingredients that'll tell you about has
really led to some amazing new phenomena
and furthermore by doing this research
what we find are different ways to
actually experimentally go out and look
for extra dimensions so I'll try to give
you a flavor of that towards the end and
extra dimensions of space could actually
be discovered in the next five years at
the Large Hadron Collider that I'll tell
you about so even if you are skeptical
about this subject and many people are
how can we choose not to explore in let
me just give you a few buzz words of
what we're going to get to in the course
of this lecture we're going to hear
about brane world's brane worlds our
exotic types of universes in which we
all live on a brain a brain first is VR
A&E it's a membrane like object in
higher dimensional space so not
everything will necessarily explore all
of the extra dimensions some things will
be stuck in a brain so we could be stuck
in a brain and I'll tell you more about
that later and if there are these brain
worlds there could be more than one
brain world leading to the idea of a
multiverse a universe in which there is
more than one brain world
which other parts only interact with us
very weakly or even not at all and these
brains were parallel you could have the
notion of parallel worlds a very
different meaning than when people talk
about when they're talking about quantum
mechanics and parallel worlds there
could be real other parallel worlds out
there parallel universes
I'll also those are some of the
buzzwords but I'm going to try to tell
you about or how extra dimensions can
illuminate connections that we wouldn't
see unless we really went to three plus
one unless we went outside three plus
one dimensional world that is to say
there were some problems we've tried
really hard and I say we I mean the
entire physics community for decades
have been trying to really hard to solve
certain problems that's defined simple
solutions it just seems that the answers
are always complicated and with extra
dimensions it seems there might actually
be simpler answers so maybe they're even
right
another thing that we found which is a
really interesting theoretical
development is that if there are extra
dimensions they can be hidden in a whole
new way before we saw that they had to
be really tiny and I'll tell you more
about that and with what we found is
that they could actually be infinitely
large and yet hidden which is really
quite remarkable and that has to do with
this warp space-time geometry that I've
been talking about I'm also going to try
to tell you a little bit about I think
this even revises how we think about our
place in the universe in fact what we
found was not only can there be infinite
extra dimensions that are unseen we
found that we can actually have what I'm
calling three dimensional sinkhole
regions of space where we observe three
dimensions of space or we think we
observe three dimensions of space even
though in other places of the universe
even maybe every place else they would
they would make measurements that which
will show higher dimensions that is to
say of the three-dimensional universe we
see can be an accident of where we're
located so I like to think of that as
the Copernican revolution continuing as
we really find out more about what our
place in the universe might be you might
wonder why such different results could
connect what why should why should these
very different phenomena I'll be
involved with very similar space-time
geometry and so just because some people
have heard of string theory some people
know about experience
just want to place the kind of research
I'm talking about in the context in the
broader context of particle physics so
high energy physics covers an enormous
range of energies we try to answer lots
of questions we're very arrogant so we
try to answer questions about very high
energies very low energies cosmology
questions about the entire universe but
at the highest energies that we think
about we know we need a new serie that's
because of the incompatibility of
quantum mechanics and general relativity
at these high energies at the energies
we observe at energy energy where we can
actually make measurements either
quantum mechanics dominates or
relativity dominates quantum mechanics
dominates on small scales atomic scales
relativity is useful when we're talking
about big scales the universe for
example but it turns out that extremely
high energies we don't know how to make
predictions both quantum mechanics and
general relativity would play a role so
we really need a theory that can resolve
this incompatibility and the best
candidate for that theory is string
theory so in string theory the
fundamental ingredients of universe are
not particles their fundamental
oscillating strings and particles are
these oscillations I'm not going to talk
in in detail about string theory but I
will use some string theory ingredients
but also I want to talk about lower
energy scales scales where we can make
measurements there's still high energies
from the perspective of the experiments
we've done in fact to test these
theories we have to look at higher
energies than anyone has ever studied
but at these lower energy scales lower
than the scales at which we understand
string theory at all there are physical
phenomena that we can study
experimentally and the hope the aim of
this is to really understand the basic
elements of matter and their
interactions that's been the goal of
particle physics for years and what we
want is to find deeper connections among
known physical quantities we know what
some of these quantities are we know
what masses are we know what
interactions are and we'd like to
understand how these are related how and
I'll tell you more about that but the
important thing about that is if we can
answer these questions a lot of the time
it will be in theories that we can test
experimentally so what we're trying to
do is ask about what the implications of
other theories
including string theory could be for the
world that we actually observe we know
the universe isn't as elegant as the
initial theory that we have of string
theory if we look around there's a lot
of messy phenomena so what we want to do
is find out how we can take the basic
ingredients and predict the phenomena
that we see in the world and the kind of
research that I do is particle physics
connected to string theory experiments
in cosmology that is to say we try to
take some of these theoretical
ingredients from string theory but make
predictions for what we see and in the
hope in that is to really make a
connection between string theories
predictions and what we have so we
really want to see how to high and low
energies connected in order to advance
our knowledge so the ideas I'll
presenter based on string theory
concepts but will concern phenomena that
we can actually go out and measure not
everything can be we can't measure
everything yet but the hope is by
studying this we'll find ways to learn
more about what the high-energy
implications are so I like to think of
this kind of research is finding trying
to make the connection at like how do
you find the best route to advance
beyond what we know today we have the
standard model of particle physics it
describes matter basic interactions and
the forces by which they interact but
it's not the whole story
and we want to go beyond that so how do
you do that well you can take the string
theory root and what string theorists
would do is say we know what the right
theory is and we're going to make
predictions based on that theory it's
very nice but the problem with that is
if you find yourself at the top of a
mountain you really want to make sure
that you're going down in the right
direction or else you end up at the top
of a cliff for example sometimes which I
have done on occasion so you really want
to make sure that you are going it the
right way on the other hand if you work
from low energy if you build up from
what we know about experiments it's
exhausting and you don't necessarily get
to the top but what I'd like to do think
is that by building up from we know from
experiment we can sort of point to what
kind of phenomena we'd like to have in
other words can we have little basic
ingredients that we would get from
string theory and that would point to
the way string theory might connect to
our world so it's not one or the other
that's going to lead to the best
advances I really think it's both
working together and the hope is that by
providing the route and actually
following it we can actually go beyond
what we know so the kind
what I do is it's called model building
and I like to think of it as adventure
travel through the world of ideas it's
really trying to find basic modules that
tell us what we really want to keep and
what we'd like to find so why are we
thinking about extra dimensions at all
though with extra dimensions we can
actually answer questions like I said
that have confused physicists for years
doesn't mean that they're necessarily
the right answers but they possibly are
they seem like simple explanations and
we can go out and test them and we can
deduce connections we would otherwise
miss to make an analogy we wouldn't
understand why intimates and Chinese
people share common features unless we
had the dimension of time so that we can
see that they're actually connected and
similarly there will be phenomena that
we won't see are connected unless we add
an extra dimension of space so we'd like
extra dimensions to show connections
that are visible the way dimension of
time has already done for us but why are
we studying extra dimensions now the
idea of extra dimensions has been around
for quite some time
one reason is string theory it turns out
that I sort of simplified the story
enormous Li but string theory it doesn't
exactly solve the problem of quantum
gravity it solves the problem of quantum
gravity that is to say combining quantum
mechanics and general relativity in a
theory with many more dimensions than we
actually see straight if string theory
is right it implies a world that has
depending on how you look at it 10 or
maybe 11 dimensions maybe even more so
the question if you believe string
theory is right it's not do these extra
dimensions exist it's why don't we see
them and could they have any
implications for the world we see as
we'll see soon string theory also injury
introduces these brains these membrane
like objects that I refer to so that's
another important reason that the study
of extra dimensions has become so
interesting in the last decade but even
if you don't believe string theory even
if you're not a string theorist you
really do have reasons to study extra
dimensions because we have no idea why
there appear to be four space-time
dimensions that is to say three
dimensions of space and one of time
there's
physical laws that we know of they tell
us there should only be three dimensions
of space
Einstein's theory of gravity Einstein's
theory of general relativity it works
for any number of dimensions it doesn't
tell us we can we have to have three
dimensions of space so it makes sense to
explore alternatives what happens when
you have extra dimensions and work out
the consequences of this theory so I
like to think of this work in some sense
is taking up where Einstein left off and
really the only way to answer the
questions of what happens when there
extra dimensions is to go out and derive
the consequences and that's what we're
trying to do but again I just want to
say I think the best reason to do it is
to seek a better understanding of our
universe and the phenomena we actually
can observe so before I go any further I
want to make sure everyone understands
what I mean when I talk about extra
dimensions so let's take a few minutes
to think about what extra dimensions
actually are the first thing I want to
say is that we think about extra
dimensions all the time we don't
necessarily think of it that way but we
think in terms of dimensions for example
if you're buying a house you'll consider
the size the location the architecture
the noise level this there's a long list
and you're making this decision in this
multi dimensional space these are
independent directions along which
you're thinking in order to make your
decision so if you think about it when
we organizing categories or information
for example in a database you can think
of a database as having
multi-dimensional entries and no one has
a problem if a database has ten entries
in it though but in some sense that's a
10 dimensional space if you try to plot
that you would have to make a 10
dimensional plot so what we what that
tells you is that it's not just
dimensions that's confusing it's when we
actually try to picture dimensions when
we have dimensions of space so how do we
think about dimensions of space so
hopefully everyone here is familiar with
three dimensions which you can think of
as the x y&z axes that are drawn there
all right you can think of the x y&z
axes here or you can just think of
up-down forward backward left right it's
a number of coordinates that you have to
give to locate someone so for example
this man here is sitting in the front
row and the second seat from the wall
and he's seated on the floor so there
are three dimensions a week
to figure out exactly where he's located
and so if there are extra dimensions we
would need more coordinates in order to
do that and in fact it's possible that
there are more dimensions that we don't
see so as I just said spatial the number
of spatial dimensions it's a number of
independent directions it's the number
of quantities you need to specify if you
want to say exactly where something is
and if you want to think about objects
in the space you can do it by
generalizing from what we know we can do
it by induction we can build it up so
let me give an example of that so you
could have geometric objects of
different dimensions and you could
imagine building them up sequentially so
let me describe what I mean so here we
have a line segments to start here which
is one dimensional line segment so if I
want to make a two-dimensional object I
can place one line segment over the
other line segment and in each of the
boundaries of the original line segment
that is to say this point in that point
I can put two a line segment that
connects these two so if one line
segment here and one line segment there
and with these four line segments I have
this two-dimensional square which is an
example of a geometric object in two
dimensions so I can continue this I can
take one Square and place it over
another Square so let's have this Square
over that Square and then at each of the
boundaries of the original Square which
in this case are these line segments I
can place a square so in this case I
have the number of squares in a cube
that make up a cube is the number of
boundary line segments we have for the
square which is 4 plus 2 the bottom one
and the top one so here we have 6
squares that make up a cube so if we
were to continue in this way you place
one cube above another cube but above in
a different dimension and you can deduce
that you would need eight cubes to make
a hypercube that's really hard to
picture Salvador Dali made a valiant
attempt at least he in this corpus
hypercube is there's actually you can't
see it very well
but there's a cube at the back and a
cube in the front there's one here one
there oh and so if you work it out
you'll see that there's the eight eight
cubes that we were talking about
and the same reason he can have this
picture though is because they're not
all connected to rake a real hypercube
these would all have to be connected in
a way that would be really very hard to
picture we try to picture we might do
some projections but they're very hard
to understand and I hope you don't spend
the rest of the lecture trying to think
about these because it could take a long
time so if this isn't good
so actually trying to picture these
extra dimensions is really hard so is
there any other way we can think about
what's going on and so some of you might
know flatland by Edwin a Abbott which
was a really clever book it was narrated
by a-square edwin a abbot and what he
had was this world called flatland which
was a two dimensional world so he had a
two dimensional world
schematically illustrated here and you
can have something that lived on this
world he had a square but it be a
two-dimensional object in a
two-dimensional world and had this very
clever idea he said if you were a
two-dimensional object living in a
two-dimensional world you would have the
same difficulty envisioning third
dimension that we in our
three-dimensional world would have
envisioning a fourth dimension or a
fifth it would be the same type of
problem so we asked what would what
would the world look like to being that
was stuck on a two-dimensional surface
the flatland of the title so for example
you could ask the question what would
happen if a sphere went through the
universe so so what would happen if you
are on this flatland is you would see a
succession of discs that grew in size
and then decreased in size you would see
slices you would see two-dimensional
slices of the 3-dimensional sphere you
can't visualize three dimensions if
you're stuck into this two-dimensional
world and only experience two dimensions
but you can see evidence of the third
dimension for example this object that
if you could see the third dimension you
would piece it together into into a
sphere so for us in our 3-dimensional
world if a hyper sphere passed through
what we would see is a series of spheres
that grew in size and then decreased in
size and we have the same problem
actually visualizing the entire object
that this flatlander had envisioning a
sphere but nonetheless it it could exist
it could
be that we for physiological reasons we
only detect three dimensions and I'm
abusing the audience and Abby went to
math camp with me where we actually saw
a really funny film of this flatland
where we had where we had little
narrator um I was um it was actually
Dudley Moore that was narrating him it's
very amusing so if you ever have a
chance to see it I recommend it so how
should we think about extra dimensions
given that we can't actually visualize
all of them well we have to somehow
reduce things to lower dimensions so
what I just told you about with slices
we can think about slices if we could
put together all those spices slices we
would have all the information about the
higher dimensional object so one way is
we knew all the lower dimensional slices
we could also do projections I showed
you an example of that with the
projections of a hypersphere
or sorry hypercube it's hard to
visualize but nonetheless has if we
could look at all the projections it
would have all the information you could
have a hologram some of you probably
have Holograms on your credit cards in
which you store information about three
dimensions in two dimensions so you can
imagine holographic versions of higher
dimensional worlds what we actually do
in practice sometimes is in sometimes
you'll see that in the pictures in my
book for example or we won't draw all
the dimensions if there's some symmetry
for example if I say all the three
dimensions of space are equivalent then
maybe I only have to draw one of them
and then I'm free to use one axis to
draw the dimensions of our world the
ones we see and then another axis to
draw an extra dimension for example so
that's sometimes a useful trick and
another one which is actually an
important physical concept that comes up
again and again in physics is that you
don't always need to know everything in
order to make predictions in other words
if there's something so small we can't
measure it for example we can just
average over it so even though those
extra dimensions are there we will get
correct predictions when we average and
if there are extra dimensions that's
what we've been doing all along without
realizing it but these are ways to try
to picture extra dimensions but I really
think that trying to picture them can
get you get you into trouble
the best way to think about a lot of the
time is through words or math to really
generalize beyond what we know and to
think about the consequences so I
like to think that when it comes to
extra dimensions a word is worth a
thousand pictures so that's extra
dimensions in general okay so that's so
when abbott wrote his book he was
talking about mathematical extranet just
how to think mathematically about extra
dimensions but what about extra
dimensions in physics when did people
start taking this notion seriously of
the of the fact that there might be
extra dimensions in the world that we
live in
well it's quite remarkable on Ted
reclusa proposed extra dimensions in
1919 the reason that's so interesting is
that was only four years after Einstein
completed his theory of general
relativity so very soon after that he
realized that we could start thinking
about worlds with an extra dimension at
the time he was trying his goal was to
unify the forces that were known then
electromagnetism and gravity and that
theory doesn't work but the idea of
extra mentions that he proposed has
survived um it's an interesting story
Einstein was actually the referee of the
paper and originally he really liked the
idea he thought this is pretty cool but
then he realized after thinking about it
for a little while that there was no
explanation at that time for why the
extra dimension is different so it's a
nice idea but what distinguishes this
extra dimension and so he actually
delayed the publication for a couple of
years and so I want to tell you now
about the answer to that question what
makes these this extra dimension
different and I'll tell you about the
old answer which has to do with extra
dimensions being very small and they're
talking about the new answer which is
based on the work that I've done so let
me first tell you about this idea of
small dimensions so the idea was to have
curled up dimensions sometimes known as
compactified dimensions and oskar klein
proposed this idea in 1926 so his idea
is very intuitive which is that if you
have the dimension that's if it's you
have a universe that's rolled up to a
really tiny size in that extra dimension
it's it could be so small that you never
notice it so let me just give an a not
analogy suppose I don't know if you can
see that very well with this light but
this is supposed to be a hose stretched
across a football field here it's a kind
of invisible football field but here's
the goal stands at the end but um if you
in looking at this hose from way on high
of course the hose looks to you to be
one-dimensional it just looks like it
has this one-dimensional extent however
if you were actually on the field for
example you would see that this hose
actually has a two-dimensional surface
or three-dimensional interior so what
this shows is that how you look at
things actually matters in terms of how
many dimensions you would ascribe to it
if you look at it very roughly you would
have thought it's one-dimensional if you
look at it up close you realize that
it's really a higher dimensional object
in a similar way the entire universe not
a host stretch across a football field
but the entire universe could be that
hose so here we have an example if we
had a two-dimensional universe and this
two-dimensional universe could be very
small in one direction but could extend
very far or infinitely far which you
can't draw in the other dimension so
let's just think about this suppose this
was the universe of course what we have
in mind er for our universe would be at
least three infinite dimensions that we
see and there could be other curled up
dimensions so let's imagine that there's
one so if you could look very closely
like the person on the football field if
you were a bug say you could walk around
this extra dimension you'd find that you
can't go very far because that extra
dimension is really tiny in size it's
just not a very big extended dimension
but if you were to go in the other
direction you would see that you could
go as far as you wanted and again if you
were a big thing you wouldn't even
notice that there was this extra
dimension if you were not sensitive if
you couldn't resolve things on that
scale that extra dimension could be
there and we wouldn't know about it so
if we have tiny curled up dimensions
they would be everywhere they'd be here
there they'd be on your on your chair on
you those extra dimensions would be
everywhere at every point in space
there's this curled up extra dimension
it's just we're not noticing it so that
was basically what everyone believed
from the time of climb proposing it
around nineteen twenty six people
gentleness I believe there were extreme
mentions but if there were extra
mentions the idea was that they had to
be rolled up to a very tiny size so what
I want to tell you about now is a new
way to hide extra dimensions which I did
with my collaborator Raman Sundra
and so it's based on this important
ingredient in string theory that I've
already mentioned namely brains so I
want to tell you more about brains for a
little bit before we go on back to that
explanation so what are these brains
brains as I said are membrane like
objects in higher dimensional space and
what what's so important about them that
was realized in the 1990s is that string
theory is not just the theory of
fundamental strings it's also the theory
of brains brains are as essential to
string theory as strings themselves in
fact strength there is something of a
misnomer someone refers to the theory
formerly known as strings and it's often
called m-theory now to indicate that it
really is this big or theory including
these other objects but what are these
brains and again I'm not sure you can
actually see here but there's a very
faint brain here can you see that at all
okay from here I can't really see so
what brains do is they distinguish
certain dimensions of space so it's like
if you had a curtain in a room or the
screen in a room for example so this
screen only is 2-dimensional even though
it's in this three-dimensional room so
if something is stuck on this screen it
would travel only in two dimensions it
wouldn't go beyond into the third
dimension and in the same way we could
have a brain
maybe that brain has three dimensions
again hard to picture so I'm picturing a
two dimensional brain here but you could
have a brain as three dimensions and it
would distinguish the directions on the
brain from this direction this one
direction in this picture off the brain
and sometimes it's higher dimensional
space with all the dimensions is known
as the bulk as opposed to the dimensions
that are just along the brain and the
reason brains are so important for us in
doing physics is that if there are these
brains they can actually trap particles
and forces so for example it could be
that the things were made up of protons
quarks that make up the nuclei electrons
analog of electrons heavier leptons they
could all be stuck on a brane so it
could be that there are extra dimensions
but the stuff of which were made and
through which we interact is stuck on a
brain and it's stuck on the brain the
same way for example you have a bead on
a wire if you have bead on
I can only travel in one dimension even
though there it might be on a
two-dimensional table or in a
three-dimensional room so if you have
beat on the wire it only experiences one
dimension and in the same way it could
be that the ingredients of the stuff
were made of where we live is stuck on a
brain and the forces through which we
interact such as electromagnetism and
the weak and strong nuclear forces could
also be stuck on a brain and if that's
true it would be very obvious to us why
we don't see the extra dimensions after
all photons have to do is
electromagnetism
light has to do it's electromagnetism
and it might just be that that's
travelling only on the brain and that we
are physiologically designed only to
detect those dimensions that are on the
brain but there's an important feature
of these brain worlds which is that not
everything is stuck on the brain so in
particular we can have objects how do
things get stuck on the brains
well the way stuff gets stuck on the
brain is because you have these strings
you could have strings that are open
strings open strings or strings with
ends and if you have these open strings
they could be anchored to the brain so
the mechanism in string theory for
having particles stuck on the brain is
to have open strings that are stuck on
brains now if that's the case only open
strings are stuck on brains if you have
a closed string that is say a string
with no ends the string that loops
around like a rubber band it won't be
stuck on a brain and in fact that's the
case for gravity so gravity is not stuck
on a brane gravity clark's corresponds
to a closed string a string that has no
ends and it turns out that if that's the
case there's no way that gravity can be
stuck on a brane it doesn't have ends
there's nothing to anchor it to the
brain but even if string theory isn't
the explanation of what we see even if
it's not string theory you know that
gravity will always know about the full
higher dimensional space and why is that
well the reason for that is that all
energy
interact via gravity gravity interacts
with energy no matter where it is or
masses wherever it is that is to say if
I have an energetic object it will
attract another energetic object no
matter where it is so it better be that
gravity is experienced everywhere that's
something we know about gravity and an
even more fundamental way of saying it
in some sense is that Einstein showed us
that gravity is connected to the
geometry of space-time
so if that's the case gravity has to
know about the full higher dimensional
space if it only knew about the brain
that it wouldn't know about the geometry
everywhere so what's so important about
brain world is that although many things
can be stuck on the brain gravity will
always experience the full higher
dimensional space which is really quite
interesting for us because if it was
everything that was stuck on a brain
then who cares about the extra
dimensions from a physics point of view
we only would see the three dimensions
of our brain and we wouldn't care that
there are these extra dimensions but
it's this fact that gravity has to know
about extra dimensions that makes extra
dimensions potentially interesting to us
so that's the whole concept that
everything except for gravity is stuck
on a brain is sometimes known as a brain
world and it's possible that this is the
case and we live in a brain world so
here's a schematic illustration of a
brain world so this brain world again is
we're imagining that there are extra
dimensions but everything we know about
is stuck on a brain and this is drawn as
two-dimensional but it's really three
dimensional and it's really infinite if
there's brain world description is right
it could be that there's a three
dimensional brain on which we live and
there is extra dimensions so we have a
person a magnet we have all the stuff we
know about except for gravity which is
stuck on this brain and if there can be
one brain in a higher dimensional
space-time we know that could actually
be more and brain world scenarios often
involve more than a single brain after
all if we have our brain world it would
be awfully chauvinistic to think that
that's the only one that's possible if
this really is the right description of
the world it's very likely that there
are extra brains with and if there are
it's really quite interesting
and let me just take us aside for about
this word this word multiverse is
sometimes used to describe that a
multiverse is sort of a funny word
because universe is by definition
supposed to be everything but
nonetheless sometimes we'll use the word
multiverse to describe independent
universes which don't interact with each
other at all that is to say they don't
have forces interacting with both of
them except for gravity or they interact
so weakly or they just don't have time
to communicate so you might have these
sort of independent brain worlds that
interact only a little bit and in that
case we would have a multiverse so here
we have our schematic illustration of a
multiverse but these multiverses are
actually quite interesting conceptually
they're very hard to test this idea so I
don't know how far we will get in
testing certain multiverse scenarios but
it's a really interesting idea because
suppose everything that we're made of is
stuck on a brain and only gravity
travels in the extra dimensions that
would mean if there are other brains
they could have fundamentally different
chemistry fundamentally different forces
there's no reason for them to replicate
the stuff that we see in our world which
is stuck on our brain so if there if
this does exist these other universes
would be exotic beyond what we could
imagine at this point and really there
are many possibilities and in this
universe of brain world we don't know
which is the right answer yet knowing
that there could be brain Wolves however
really changes the higher-dimensional
landscape it really introduces the
possibility that there are all sorts of
exotic possibilities that we haven't yet
considered so we've already said their
communal versus with curled up
dimensions I'm going to talk about
universes with these warped extra
dimensions and we will see that extra
dimensions could be large or even
infinite they don't have to be tiny and
curled up and in some of these brane
world scenarios we have a universe with
a single brain sometimes we would have
many brains and what we the goal of
physicists is to find out is is any of
these do any of these theories actually
describe our world so at this point
there are so many possibilities that I
like to think of extra dimensions or
physicists playground these brain worlds
are like a jungle gym we really want to
know how to put together these
ingredients to get to get the kind of
things that we see and which of them can
be tested but I just want to say that
at least theoretically we've really come
a long way now and I'm sure there's
still a lot remaining to be studied but
with brains as I said we found another
way to high dimensions that is to say we
could have these warp dimensions which
I'll tell you about we have a new way to
explain the weakness of gravity which is
a question I'll come back to and as I
alluded to earlier we really might have
this new concept of our place in the
universe we might have these
three-dimensional sinkholes so first let
me tell you about this idea of hiding a
dimension and this is work I did with my
collaborator Raman syndrome so this
called the RS to brain world because
it's the second paper that we did on the
subject but there actually is only a
single brain and as we're going to see
our s1 is going to involve two brains so
it's very confusing terminology but this
brain world is a way to hide a dimension
so what we have here is this gravity
brain now on this gravity brain which is
the brain world I told you about earlier
on which were stuck in living in general
we would expect to have some energy on
this brain now what Einstein theory of
general relativity tells us is that if
there's energy it affects the geometry
however we know that we live in a large
basically flat universe so we know that
it shouldn't be curled up it shouldn't
be wrinkled it shouldn't so if there is
this energy it has to be balanced
somehow so to get a large flat brain
you also need energy in the bulk and you
can have competition between this higher
dimensional energy this energy that
spreads throughout the Xtra mentions and
energy on the brain and it could be
tuned just in a right the right way that
we could have this large flat brain
world which could conceivably describe
where we live what we found in the
scenario is that you can actually have
an infinite extra dimension so let me
try to give a flavor for why that's true
so I call this idea localized gravity so
let me explain here we have the gravity
brain which was that brain that carried
that positive energy what we find is
that gravity is concentrated near this
brain that is to say although in
principle gravity can leak out into the
and practice it does it very little so
gravity is indeed everywhere in the way
I said it has to be but really it's all
concentrated here so what I have here is
this graviton probability function for
those of you who know about quantum
mechanics you know that for every
particle you have you have this wave
function associated with it so what the
particle we're considering now is the
graviton what the graviton is it's a
particle that communicates the force of
gravity
it's the analog of a photon which is the
particle that communicates
electromagnetism so it's the theory of
gravity is right there's a particle
called the graviton and what we found
about this graviton probability function
is that it's heavily concentrated near
the gravity brain it's exponentially
bigger here than further out so there's
a tiny probability for gravity to leak
away from the brain because it's
concentrated so heavily here and
practice the graviton is very rarely
away far away and when we work out the
math we find it's exponentially falling
it's really heavily concentrated near
the brain so you can also understand
this set by a sort of more classical
argument so let's consider the
gravitational field near our brain so
what we have here is some massive
objects sitting on a brain now what
these lines are these gravitational
field lines the density of these lines
tells us how strong gravity is so for
example if you look just on this
direction here the semicircle here near
the massive object these lines are very
heavily concentrated near each other so
gravity would be relatively strong but
as you go further away these lines are
more dilute so so the gravity would be
weaker which corresponds to the fact
that growt the force of gravity
decreases as you go away from a massive
object so the density of these lines is
telling us how strong gravity is now the
important thing is that along the brain
these lines spread out equally that is
to say there's no preferred direction
along the brain so gravity those
gravitational field lines would spread
out equally strongly in all three
dimensions of space that we know about
now if this was true in the fourth
dimension as well then the force of
gravity wouldn't look like what we see
it would look like a force corresponding
a for spacial dimensional world because
it would be spreading out more quickly
it would be spreading out into this
extra dimension but that's not what
happens in this warped geometry in this
warped geometry the field lines don't
spread very much in this extra dimension
they Bend around so you as you can
imagine there would be some straggling
lines that come all the way out here but
they're extremely dilute there's
virtually no gravity here there's a
little bit but it's very weak near the
brain these lines are much denser so
effectively what happens is that gravity
doesn't really spread into this extra
dimension this is an exaggerated drawing
in fact it spreads just so
infinitesimally that we wouldn't notice
in practice gravity is in this warped
geometry with this exponentially falling
graviton wavefunction gravity is really
spreading only on the brain it's hardly
getting into the extra dimension at all
which says that the size of the extra
dimension just doesn't matter it could
be infinitely big and we wouldn't know
it so at the time I did this work I
actually was laid up on crutches for a
little while it's pretty soon afterwards
so this is an analogy which may or may
not be helpful to you but it certainly
struck me at the time which is that you
if you're suppose you're on crutches
then you don't have the energy to walk
around a whole lot so if you're inside a
house you don't care very much whether
the door is open or shut you're pretty
much stuck inside it's just
energetically unfavorable to leave the
house a lot so you might be locked in in
which case you really are staying in the
house or the door might be open but in
practice you just don't go out very much
and it's somewhat like that if you think
about what happens with this with these
tiny dimensions versus this localized
gravity scenario if there are tiny
dimensions that means there really is no
possibility of going beyond the distance
of the size of that dimension you're
really stuck in its light locked door
you really can't go beyond that but if
there's this localized gravity it's more
like it's just energetically unfavorable
for gravity to leak gravity is sort of
holding itself in so that it stays near
the brain even though in principle it
could go arbitrarily far away so just to
summarize what I've been saying extra
dimensions can be infinite in size
if geometry is warped in the way I've
described if higher dimensions of work
we wouldn't know about it
that is to say all the experiments we do
that tell us that there are three
dimensions of space might equally well
be telling us that we live in this
warped higher dimensional world they
just a virtually experimentally
indistinguishable it really looks as if
there are only three dimensions of space
so it's really an alternative to rolled
up dimension the dimension is extremely
well hidden and we found something even
more dramatic that four dimensions
itself could be an accident of location
that is to say if you are near the brain
you would see three plus one dimensions
and the theory I just told you about no
matter where you are you would go out
and measure the fact that there are only
three dimensions of space but it's
possible to have theories in which you
would only see think that you see three
dimensions of space if you're in a
particular location which is near a
brain so you could be living on this
four dimensional island there could be
five dimensions or ten dimensions even
eleven but and if you're anywhere else
other than on this four dimensional
island in the higher dimensional space
you would think there were more
dimensions if you went and made
measurements obviously it wouldn't be us
but if higher dimensional creatures went
out and made measurements they would
think that they were actually higher
dimensions of space but we could
nonetheless be living in this sort of
gravitational island where we don't
experience the extra dimensions at all
so sometimes I call that a four
dimensional sinkhole or three
dimensional space there stinkle four
dimensional space-time sinkhole so these
are rather interesting results I mean
these were things that people didn't
know about for a seventy years after
Einstein's theory and after the idea of
extra dimensions was introduced but as a
physicist they're also fairly
frustrating because what I'm telling you
is that there could be something as
dramatic as an infinite extra dimension
or even these pockets of lower
dimensional space and higher dimensions
and we wouldn't know about it which
leads to the kind of obvious question if
we're ever going to be able to test this
warped extra dimension well we are there
any tests we can do and the answer is
yes but there's a copy
we can test it if there's a connection
to particle physics so let me give you
an example of how that might work so
this has to do with something that's
known as the hierarchy problem and it
might sound like a technical problem but
it's really one of the biggest puzzles
in particle physics that is to say for
the last 30 years or so
high-energy physicists have been
puzzling away at this problem and they
just haven't no one has come up with a
really satisfactory answer so what is
the question the question it can be
phrased as why is gravity so weak
compared to the other elementary forces
now gravity might not actually seem all
that way to you for example when you're
hiking or when something falls on you
but actually gravity is an extremely
weak force for example if you had a
magnet it could pick up a paperclip even
though it's competing a tiny magnet can
compete against the entire earth so
gravity only seems strong because it's
the entire Earth that's acting on your
vehicle if you had something the size of
a magnet competing only via
gravitational force it would be
infinitesimal and from the point of view
of elementary particles gravity is
totally negligible gravity is much
weaker than the other fundamental forces
that we know which are electromagnetism
and the weak and strong nuclear forces
it's many orders of magnitude weaker and
this is the puzzle we want to answer why
is it so much weaker and it's really
quite a big puzzle because it's not just
the question of why do we have these two
very different scales we want to know it
if you were to give a particle physicist
the problem of how do you think these
scales are related if they didn't
already know the answer and they went
out and did a calculation they would say
that those scales should be very similar
and in reality they are separated by
sixteen orders of magnitude these are
hugely separated scales sixteen orders
of magnitude is bigger than the number
of key notes that you can put in to end
in the universe it's an enormous number
so I'm telling you that we have to put
in a fudge factor that's tuned sixteen
digits of precision to get the right
answer so as I told you earlier the
standard model works really well
it describes all the things we know
about it describes their interactions
but to get the standard model right if
you were to put in just a simple
expose them which is something some of
you might have heard of if you explain
masses with just a Higgs boson you have
to put in a fudge factor of sixteen
orders of magnitude along with that to
get it right so one of the questions
particle no-one believes that's really
the case so we want to know why that
happens so I was delighted what I was in
the Museum of Modern Art because there's
this broken obelisk sculpture which is
sort of illustrates this idea of why
it's problem of this fine-tuning problem
so if you were to see something like
this most of the time you would see it
surrounded by say yellow tape or
something or you saw in a chipmunk
cartoon you would say stay away but
nonetheless some this stays up and it
stays up because it's basically
fine-tuned I mean someone designed it so
that this is a stable configuration so
what we want to find is why this this
configuration that we have in our theory
is stable what is it that makes it
satisfying we don't want to have to put
in this huge fudge factor that tells us
that things are just right to make them
work we believe that they should be
fundamentally something different this
fact that we are getting this wrong
naively tells us it's actually very
interesting because it tells us how to
go beyond what we know how to go beyond
the standard model or at least it
indicates the kind of directions we want
to go in and to solve this problem
people have come up with very exotic
ideas some of you might have heard of
supersymmetry in which we double the
part at number of particles around so
that's one possibility but when you try
to work out the details of that theory
it becomes very complicated and it's
hard to believe that the theories we
know about are really what's going on in
some cases unless there are extra
dimensions so it's really worthwhile to
explore extra dimensions and see does it
provide a more satisfying alternative so
I'm going to explain to you now why
extra dimensions might solve this
problem of the weakness of gravity in a
very satisfactory way so we have in some
sense a multiverse here we have the
gravity brain which has this positive
energy I told you about but this is
theory is different there's a second
brain which I'm going to call the weak
brain and now the weak brain is actually
where we're going to live that's why I
put all the objects that live on the
brain here so no longer is it living on
the gravity brain it's on the second
brain this weak brain so now we have two
brains gravity will still be concentrate
on the
gravity brain but we're going to be
living on the second brain the weak
brain and if you think about it it's
very natural for gravity to be weak here
because what I argued before is that
this graviton probability function is
only it has an exponentially suppressed
probability to be found here it's a tiny
probability to be here so things that
live on this weak brain have a much
weaker gravitational interaction with
each other so it's very naturally for
there to be an exponential suppression
of the strength of gravity so the 16
orders of magnitude just has to do with
the fact that these two brains have some
modest separation for each other if
they're separated enough for the
strength of gravity to fall
exponentially it's a natural consequence
of the Warped geometry and there's
another way of thinking about this which
I really like
in some sense what happens in this
warped geometry one way to understand
the Warped geometry is that your scale
size changes as you go out in an extra
dimension so if you want to measure
things here as very small something that
you would measure here is very small on
the other brain you would mention it
measure is very big so Alice in
Wonderland naturally comes to mind
who's going to increase in size if she
were to reverse this fifth dimension
with the cat as her guide here the bulk
cap so what you have up here is that the
actual scale would change that's that's
one way of understanding this warped
geometry the way you would measure
things actually changes as you go out in
this extra mention and not just sizes
and lengths would change how we would
measure mass and energy would change so
something that you would expect to be
very normally heavy here you would
expect to be much smaller there
exponentially smaller in mass so that is
to say if you if you want to explain a
very naturally a separation between
energies say this energy that's
associated with weakness of gravity and
another energy that's associated with
the weak force which is really what the
hierarchy problem is about this huge
separation between these two energies
between these two masses it's very
natural here because gravity is
concentrated here but the stuff we're
made of is concentrated here so the
gravitational force that we experience
here is much smaller because thing
are so much lighter after all gravity
knows about how massive things are so
it's when stuff has less mass it would
have a weaker gravitational attraction
and that's really what's going on in
this explanation for the weakness of
gravity in this warped five dimensional
space-time so that's kind of an exotic
idea so is it right well how would we
know that
well we'd want to perform some tests
we'd want to know and so what I want to
explain to you in the remaining few
minutes is that this is actually
testable we can actually go out and do
experiments and see whether this is
right and the first reason for that is
because of this connection to mass and
the weakness of gravity relative to the
other forces this is precisely what
we're trying to study that is to say the
generalized we of physicists this is
exactly what particle physicists want to
go out and measure precisely the energy
where we can address this question of
the weakness of gravity and how
particles acquire mass how fundamental
elementary particles get their mass so
we're going to be performing Collider
experiments and they're going to have
the right energy to answer this question
let me just tell you what kind of
Collider experiment and come back to
what exactly we're going to be looking
for so the particular Collider that is
going to be extremely exciting and it's
going to turn on in two years it's going
to start operation two years it's called
the LHC the Large Hadron Collider and
what we have here it's and it's located
in accelerated facility at CERN which is
near Geneva very close to the French
border and what it is is an enormous
underground ring 27 kilometers in
circumference and what happens in this
ring is that protons are accelerated to
extremely high energy and you have two
proton beams that are accelerated to
extremely high energy that are going to
collide with each other and create an
enormous amount of energy in the process
now why do we want an enormous amount of
energy well from Einstein we know that e
equals MC squared so if we want to make
massive particles particles with big
mass M we need to have high energy E so
what we want to do is build high energy
accelerators so we can probe heavier
objects and the reason we want to probe
heavier objects is
these are very likely going to tell us
what is the answer to the questions I've
been asking so in particular if this
extra dimensional explanation this warp
space-time dimensional explanation of
the weakness of gravity is right we can
look for something called Colusa Cline
particles which these clues decline
particles are particles they're named
after the concern finally I mentioned
earlier but what they are are particles
that travel in the extra dimensions so
if extra dimensional theory is right if
this theory is right the gravity is in
the extra dimensions so there would be
partners of grab this graviton particle
I told you about but they would be
heavier they'd be heavier because they
have momentum or energy associated with
their motion in the extra dimensions so
there could be these particles that
would look to us like heavy particles
they would have properties similar to
the particles we see but they would be
much heavier and these are their clue to
Cline particles and what we want to do
is find these gluts with Cline particles
and we have an idea of their mass
because their mass is determined by the
extra dimensional geometry if you know
all the clues to climb particles if you
know everything about them their
interactions in their masses you could
deduce what the higher dimensional
geometry is and conversely if you know
that higher dimensional geometry the
higher dimensional set up you can deduce
what the masses of these particles
should be and in this theory that
addresses this question of the weakness
of gravity it turns out that these
Colusa klein particles have precisely
the mass that we would want in order to
be able to test them look for them at
this collider so what will it look for
well what happens is approach on two
protons collide together just working
two protons collide together and what
happens is say a court there are quarks
inside a proton there there's actually
anti quarks as well so these quark and
antiquark would to collide together and
they would annihilate each other that is
the state they would turn into pure
energy and once we have this energy that
energy can turn into massive particles
for example this cludes the Klein
particle so if there are these heavy
gluts a Cline particles
we go to high enough energy we'll be
able to make them and what's so exciting
about this particular theory is that we
will be able to in some sense see these
particles the way we've seen other heavy
particles people thought that if there
are extra dimensions the only way you
could find them is you would look for
what's called missing energy what you
would see is that you don't see things
you would see their stuff that leaks off
into the extra dimensions and that's
fine but if you it's kind of hard to pin
down that that is a theory of extra
dimensions you don't know that but in
this particular theory that I told you
about these gluts decline particles will
actually decay inside the detector that
is to say they will turn into things
that we can actually go out and measure
in this case an electron and anti
particle positron but other things as
well that we can go out and look for and
what's so exciting about that is then we
can actually deduce all the properties
of the Colusa klein particle we can
calculate its mass based on the energy
of the decay products we can identify
certain features that would tell us that
it's really this extra dimensional
theory for there's a property that has
to do with the spin of a particle
what kind of angular momentum it looks
like it has the details aren't important
what's important is that by studying the
properties of these decay products we
would be able to do specific properties
that would tell us this particle is
actually associated with gravity and if
that's the case it's very likely
connected to this higher dimensional
theory this very there's just no other
series that would likely give us a
signature like this so there really are
tests we can do that were expert not we
I do theory but test experimentals will
do to see do these particles exist and
is this theory right and I should say
that even if this theory isn't right it
will look for other it will look for
evidence of other theories no matter
what Theory answers this question of how
do we solve the hierarchy problem there
should be evidence for it at the Large
Hadron Collider which is why is it's so
exciting and it's why I try to give some
background in the book to tell it so
that when that eclair comes and actually
presents results you'll know what what
it's actually telling you so I think if
extra dimensions solve the hierarchy
problem we'll know about it if anything
solves a hierarchy problem we should
know about but extra dimensions or one
of the possibilities and I should say
that depending on exactly the energies
of what's out there if we're
very lucky and the energies are right we
would even be able to see five
dimensional black holes because in
Caesarea is fundamentally five
dimensional at the energies we would be
able to observe it's conceivable there
would be five dimensional black holes
don't worry about this these private
mansion black holes will actually decay
right away they're not big objects
they're going to suck everything and
they're going to disappear before too
long but it'd be extremely exciting to
see evidence of black hole five
dimensional black holes and another
thing that's really interesting is that
people always think and it's very it
might be true that string theory is
beyond what we can test experimentally
one reason for that is that if there are
extra heavy particles associated with
other oscillations of the string we
expect them to be extremely heavy
sixteen orders of magnitude beyond what
we can see with experiments however as
I've tried to give some flavor of
because of the warp geometry if stuff is
on the weak brain at our collider
experiments are in the weak brain if
we're on the weak brain stuff there is
sixteen orders of magnitude lighter than
you would expect
so even string States could conceivably
be within the reach of Collider
experiments it's not necessarily going
to happen we'll have to be lucky but
it's conceivable that we can really go
out and see these worked the evidence of
the warp geometry because there would be
this these light string States it would
be extremely exciting so this is about
all I can tell you in the amount of time
I have but um I'd like to say I'd like
you to have the idea at least that I
really think we're entering a new era in
physics um and this is you know we're
really going to explore this new energy
scale where the answer to this question
we'll learn it and basically there's no
theory that's out there as I said a lot
of theories are complicated but all of
the theories will tell us something
really fundamentally interesting it
might be that these extra dimensions it
might be that there's extra symmetries
of the world symmetries a space-time
that we didn't know about we're going to
learn something very new and there's
really many exciting ideas for what we
might discover and we know these
connections are there and we just want
to find them so I like to think that
secrets of the universe are about to
unravel so I'll just close with this
picture from the tape Museum which I
like which I think sort of a
schematically illustrates how I think we
find ourselves we sort of live in the
stencil world we
the only the tail-end but there's a
world out there that we're only
beginning to discover so thank you very
much I'm happy to answer questions and I
assume there are some but if you do have
a question please go to the microphone
do you foresee a time when we might be
able to go to one or more of these extra
dimensions for extra universes other
than just with words or by mathematics
the way we went to the moon um well I
the answer is I don't see that right now
but you know we're very limited in our
imagination a lot of the time the fact
that I don't see it right now doesn't
mean it will never happen um but it
could be that the laws of physics
prevent it from happening but what we
might be able to do if we're really
lucky one day is if this idea is right
maybe there would be gravitational
signals that go back and forth between
our universe and another one I mean
there are some things that are
physically permitted that might actually
happen eventually and you know sometimes
people ask me about like applications
and I like to tell them that you know
when when Einstein wrote down his theory
of general relativity he said I'm pretty
sure he didn't think that they were be
useful in things like GPS systems I mean
so you know we just don't know where
things are going to end up I mean one of
the really exciting things that I
mentioned also in my book is that you
know it was actually people doing
particle physics that actually ended up
coming up with a world wide web because
there were people scattered all over the
globe and they want to be able to
interact directly and so actually it's
turned was where the World Wide Web was
first developed so you know we don't
know these things now I mean we can you
know I can tell you about things I mean
I'm really trying to to be very fair and
honest about what we know based on
physics right now I mean we can
speculate about many different ideas but
really what one of the things I really
want to accomplish and write in my book
is to say why are we thinking about
these exotic ideas I mean I could just
present them and tell you them and they
all sound very magical but how did we
get there what are the problems we're
trying to solve and how would
know if these things are right and so I
could speculate about that but really in
terms of physics we don't really have
any ideas for that right now I'm I'm
interested in hearing more about the
Large Hadron Collider and what exactly
is going to happen as soon as they get
it to start working or is there going to
be a queue of all the world physicists
that are going to want to run
experiments in it do they have their own
agenda in terms of what expression so
it's actually really excited I mean this
is a big massive operation or massive in
a different sense here but so it's
actually a globe so so CERN itself was
originally a European facility it was
formed after World War two and it was a
place where all European physicists come
together so the experiments at CERN are
designed all over Europe but actually
for the Large Hadron Collider it's
really all over the globe the United
States is participating Japan is
participating these experiments are
really beating the designer and there's
two big experiments that that will
address questions like this is actually
five experiments but two that are doing
the kind of things that were that I'm
talking about here
and people pretty much know who they are
and so you know there's a massive
coordination I mean there's a hundreds
of physicists involved and eat both of
these experiments five thousands
actually and so so there would be like a
well-defined you know running time I
mean basically how it's going to work
will depend how well the machine works
right away I mean there'll be some
downtime to upgrade to make things work
but it's both building the accelerator
and building the experiments that are
going on and right now they're building
the accelerator and the experiments and
so we we know which experiments will be
in there and so all of us theorists are
anxiously awaiting to find out how well
the accelerator will work and then in
those two things I mean one is we want
to get to high energy but another thing
that we're care about is something
called luminosity which is basically how
many events there are how often do these
collisions happen and the higher the
luminosity the more we can see because
if something has a small probability of
happening the more collisions we have
the more likely we are to see it so it's
really we're going to be waiting to get
the luminosity that we want to see some
of these more exotic events
several questions I'm really not sure
where to begin so I'll pose the one that
I think is more exotic I've read a lot
about what they call dark energy and
dark matter in space and I know that up
to this point there's no way they can be
actually detected or measured or
quantified could there be some
connection between can I stop you there
for a second yeah um so first of all I
mean we this what it is is not measured
but the existence of dark energy just
for people who don't know the existence
of dark energy and dark matter is
measured because we know their
gravitational effects we don't know what
they are but we do know they exist in
terms of dark matter we actually have
lots of experiments that are out there
looking for dark matter candidates so
it's conceivable they can be detected
they just haven't been yet okay the
second thing that also caught my
attention I've had several chances to
speak to dr. Misha okay Kawai sort of
known through City College and instead
of looking at things in multiple
dimensions working their way up to ten
or eleven with M theory etc is it
possible that we suspect there are
dimensions that don't exist such as like
a hologram where it's really in two
dimensions but it appears to be in three
so um so people I mean one of the things
I get to just towards the end there's a
lot of very deep questions that exist
even what fundamentally does the
dimension mean and it really are some
very exotic phenomena that we see in
string theory and even in the kind of
warped theories that I've told you about
there are theories that actually look
equivalent so you can have five
dimensional theories that look
equivalent to four dimensional theories
now how can that be well obviously not
everything is the same in those theories
so you can have for example why do I say
string theory can have 10 or 11
dimensions well you can look at certain
regions of string interactions so if
strings interact very strongly
sometimes the best description of that
theory isn't the 10 dimensional theory
its own alternative 11 dimensional
theory which is really the same theory
but in that various strings are weakly
interacting so we can make predictions
because we can only make predictions
when there are a weak interactions in
general if there are strong interactions
we have no systematic way
of getting an expansion but you can
imagine if interactions are weak you can
start off with no interactions at all
then add a little bit in my book I talk
about it in terms of sort of mixing
paint you might want to get it precise
color and you'd start save with a lot of
blue and then add a little bit of green
but so you can do this sort of
perturbation Theory you can do that so
what happens is if you look for certain
regimes of string coupling it's best
described as ten dimensional theory
other regimes that's best described as
eleven dimensional theory that means
that at some level we don't really know
what we're talking about when we talk
about dimensions we certainly understand
dimensions on the scales we see but
maybe at a fundamental level and maybe
if we understood string theory better or
whatever is the theory of quantum
gravity better we can understand that so
it could be that we see more dimensions
but there are these holographic
dimensions so we could be equivalent to
another theory I mean you know we have
these puzzles like the puzzle of dark
energy why is there the amount of energy
that's seen in the world why isn't it
very big and why isn't it zero I mean
why is it what it is and it could be
that fundamentally gravity is very
different but these are nice
speculations but no one's really put any
meat on those bones yet okay thanks good
this is not so much a question as an
attempt to get a clarification of the
schema that you outlined I understanding
is that you've explained the weakness of
gravity by the separation between the
weak brain and the gravity brain such
that the fault just as in classical
physics the fall-off of gravity is
inversely proportional to distance what
you've done is sort of generalize that
so that the distance shall we say
separating your weak brain and the
gravity brain is such that it explains
the weakness in some sense is
reminiscent of the classical it's
reminiscent but it's actually very
different in one very critical respect
yes which is that it's exponentially
falling yeah usually you think things
are spreading out the same way in all
dimensions I mean the really novel
feature we found it was this very
different warped geometry that only
happens because the space-time is so
warped space-time weren't warped then
you would need something to be six
whereas a magnet away or whatever to
dilute something or however many okay
this case it would have to be even more
so it would have to be really far away
but in the reason you can and the reason
I don't like that is how do you explain
this huge distance that's just another
hierarchy problem that you're
introducing exactly what's nice here is
there isn't really this big heart it's
very easy to find theories where two
brains are a modest distance apart right
it's just hard to get them really far
apart so it's this exponential that's
really critical right so right so that
the difference from the classical so now
the point I'd like to clarify is if you
do find extra mass associated with the
Kaluza klein particles your explanation
is going to be that this energy comes
from the extra dimension and I'm just
clarifying now that would mean that
separation that I talked about between
the weak brain and the gravity brain
except not so much the separation as the
emphasis on the exponential fall off
exactly so that's that's what is that
Lee insightful actually because when
people work out these clues to climb
particles yes Umbridge initely I mean
the glute vision include to climb
particles there wasn't this warping so
the only thing that determined the extra
dimensions was the size so the masses of
these particles were connected to the
size of the extra dimensions so you and
in fact it inversely with the size right
kind of makes sense because if it's
bigger it's more accessible it would be
lighter right and so it is in this
theory yes it's not determined just by
that separation in fact it's more
determined by the curvature the
curvature this warping is the curvature
and that determines how things fall out
okay and it's an exponential function
you talked about
yeah and it's basically how quick that
exponential Falls and okay it's both the
exponential and how quick it is that's
determinate it's really how how quickly
it's falling that's determining these
masses okay that's why it's different
not only respect to the masses but also
with respect to the interactions the
interactions are much stronger than you
would naively expect because of this
warping which is why I could actually
decay in the detector and not just
disappear into the extra dimensions okay
this is not so much a question as a
clarification in my own understanding of
your work thank you very much thank you
um wasn't one of the motivations for the
egg theory was the
attempting to remove the probabilistic
nature of quantum mechanics and somehow
make it into a more deterministic one um
actually no I think you know lots of
people puzzle about the nature of
quantum mechanics but I mean I tell ni
to to I talk about quantum mechanics in
my book and really the prompt the
puzzles we get into a quantum mechanics
is because we always try to understand
quantum mechanics and classical terms
but really if quantum mechanics is
fundamentally right its classical
physics that we understand from quantum
mechanics and it's true if we can say
why for big things that we usually see
things look classical and why quantum
mechanics works or we need to take
quantum mechanics into account at small
scales really string theory was designed
to resolve this conflict between quantum
mechanics and gravity at certain scales
the fact that we it looks I mean what
this theoretical inconsistently tells us
is neither one can possibly be the final
answer there has to be a more
encompassing theory but if there is that
more in cost encompassing theory it will
look like quantum mechanics on atomic
skills it will look like general
relativity on big scales I mean that
we've tested this we know that that
better be right so what we're going to
find is a theory that is fundamentally
different but on the scales we observe
should lead to the same consequences
if there are there any other questions
well if there's anything else you don't
understand I assure you